[Music]
so I've been doing this show 26 years
answering people's financial questions
I'm a baby boomer so when we started out
we were dealing with baby boomer
problems and they the baby boomers were
in their 30s when I started this out
early 30s and there was this bunch of
characters coming up behind the baby
boomers called the Gen Xers skateboard
crowd and they were going up ramps and
flipping around on skateboards and crazy
people and they were here reverent like
the baby boomers were not a bunch of
hippies that were here Reverend in the
70s which they were every generation is
irreverent when it starts it should
Winston Churchill said when you're young
if you're not a liberal and when you're
old if you're not a you're a fool and
you're also a fool if by the time you're
old you're not a conservative so it's
the way things start it's the way things
go let me just tell you there's nothing
more capitalistic than an old hippie
from the 70s they know how to make money
I'll tell you that so yeah it just
changes everything right so then the Y
generation comes along and every
generation have you noticed if you're a
little bit older like me that every
generation gets trashed like the Xers
when they were coming up everybody
trashed them the why oh the Y generation
they were the they had no tethering they
weren't tied to anything they just were
adrift and and they went by pretty quick
actually and then we land into the
Millennials oh those dastardly
Millennials every generation gets
trashed but have you figured out yet are
you old enough to figured out that every
generation has got some good people in
it and everybody every generation it's
got some bad people in it there are some
lazy bums there's some people of no
character there are some people who are
just absolutely foolish and there are
some people who are noble that serve
they care about others that are
compassionate in every generation there
are and so the stereotype of generation
is just shows stereotyped anything real
he's pretty much shows your ignorance
right
what I just did I just said everybody
who's stereotypes I was organized yeah
this slide just generalized I could
prove the point right but it's logic
meltdown right there
but yeah so the Millennials are all what
what are they all there they're all
participation trophy entitled brats
living in their mother's basement
they're useless
have you heard all this I gotta tell you
it's not true oh there is some
participation trophy entitled Occupy
Wall Street brats that one of you know
anarchy socialism Bo I know life's not
fair my education costs too much I'm a
victim there's there's a percentage of
those characters out there floating
around no doubt about it but that is not
really the Millennial Generation they're
they're really truthfully I but I know
this because I've got a building full of
we got seven or nineteen people here and
over half of them or Millennials and we
have an incredibly high pressure
hard-working world-class excellence team
we play for the Super Bowl every day or
you get fired here we're not mean about
it we just played a win you can't catch
a pass you get to sit on the bench we're
doing what we do
why'd freaking open every day and half
of them are Millennials unbelievably
good at what they do and they care
deeply let me tell you this generation
more than any generation I've ever
worked with if you get the good ones
they care more deeply they will charge
the gates of Hell with a water pistol I
mean they because they're cause driven
their mission driven it's a it's a
wonderful generation again the ones that
are bums they're just bumps and that you
can pick them out pretty quick because
there's really no middle ground with
this bunch they're proud of being bums
or they're proud of being mission driven
social justice oriented get stuff done
for the other people compassionate
people I love them they're easy to work
with so I really don't like it when
stuff like this 30 year old deadbeat
son gets kicked out of his house thing
makes big news it's on all the news
feeds and everybody wearing out the
Millennials because here's another one
of those dastardly Millennials he's 31
years old he wouldn't move out his
parents had to have him evicted he's 30
years old had to have him evicted so
they took him to court and the judge
evicting him now here's the thing we do
have a sociological aaja chol problem in
our culture we've got a Arrested
Development issue issue where people
aren't developing and emotionally we
know this because 29 percent of the
males between age 20 and age 30 still
live at home that's one out of three
males now you notice I didn't call them
men they still live at home now we can
call it their fault we can call it
mama's fault we can call it daddy's
fault we can call it the government's
fault it might be the Democrats fault
it's probably george w bush's fault but
we're not sure whose fault it is but
somebody needs to take the blame for
this disastrous mess of these males who
are not developing into men manhood
crisis the woosah fication of america so
these people have this 30 year old
living in their basement and they can't
get him out well let me help you with
this I am NOT an attorney but I own a
bunch of rental property and I am
virtually certain in every state in the
Union that a guest who is staying in
your personal home does not fall under
tenant law when a guest does not leave
your personal residence that is a guest
of yours when you request for them to
leave you throw their butt in the street
physically if you have to and if you
can't pull that off you have the sheriff
come by and go I can't get this guy out
of my house he won't leave now that's
not a
and an eviction so is this guy a bum
this thirty years old absolutely but did
these parents create this you dadgum
right they did if you have a thirty year
old living in your basement it was a
problem a long time ago it was a problem
five years ago this is not a new problem
and they wrote him a letter let me tell
you somebody's in my house I'm not
writing I'm not a wuss okay you would
suffice parents you go down the hall you
grab him by his belt you toss his butt
in the driveway and throw his little
mp3's out the window after him or
whatever he's gonna take with him his
MacBook Air you know whatever he's gonna
do right just take whatever it is
Millennials take when they leave and go
but I mean that's that's by the time
it's gotten to that point what we know
is is that this guy's thirty when this
guy was 12 no one taught him no one
taught him how to work no one taught him
how to save no one taught him that the
expectation is is that when you are an
adult you will not be living here my
kids had real clear understanding we're
paying for college and don't come home
unless you bring grandbabies and that's
called a visit now I if you have a major
problem
I don't mind mom and dad being a safety
net but this idea that mom and dad are a
hammock is a bad idea so if you're 26
years old and you're pissed off at me
right now cuz you live in your mommy's
basement good grow a backbone stand up
on your two feet like you're a grown man
and start making a plan to be on your
own I'm saving money you're a wuss
get out in the world save money by
getting in a roommate pay your own bills
make your own omelet in the morning and
learn to press your own pants and shirt
oh and learn to sew on a button too
young man it'll be good for you when
you're on the road one day actually
working and the
button comes off your shirt this is
called parenting skills people this is
not this guy's fault it's partly this
guy's fault he's a bum
but these parents bosses unbelievable
I got to tell you what I've never gotten
this far at the Ramseys we going all
hillbilly on you long before that this
is the Dave Ramsey show